c'était une grande première pour le
tournoi de la balle dehors des yvelines
des joueurs handisport ont intégré la
compétition départementale cette année
au total trois joueurs en fauteuil et
six joueurs de boue se sont inscrits
auprès des organisateurs
on a créé dont deux tableaux on a créé
un tableau fauteuil ce qu'on appelle un
tableau assise et un tableau 2 de glee
on n'a pas l'habitude de les voir comme
ça dans une épreuve départementale donc
c'est ça qui s'apprend s'est montré un
petit peu à tout le monde ce qu'ils sont
capables de faire
et puis de voir que finalement c'est pas
si facile de jouer contre eux parce que
ils ont aidé d'autres méthodes de jeu et
ils savent aussi embêtée leurs
adversaires pour remporter des victoires
ce dimanche 3 juin guyancourt certains
pongistes sont passés par plusieurs mois
d'entraînement c'est le cas de sandrine
copains du club de voisins-le-bretonneux
à jouer ce test au tennis de table
depuis un an
j'en ai fait un petit peu en valide donc
de me retrouver en fauteuil puisque
maintenant je suis handicapé et devoir
trouver le ja c'est plus le même geste
donc c'est beaucoup il faut oublier tout
ce que je savais avant quoi donc c'est
compliqué une fois le geste maîtriser
place à la stratégie yorick hadjal
joueurs de l'équipe de france à son plan
de bataille
le ping pong fauteuil est beaucoup plus
tactique et c'est plus technique que le
troupeau valide le placement par les
différents on va être lésé sur certaines
balles donc il faut vraiment
stratégiquement réfléchir à tous c'est
un vrai jeu c'est bien un vrai jeu
d'échecs en fait c'est vrai qu'elle ait
des zones sont très gênante pour nous en
fauteuil donc on va chercher à alizée
notre adversaire pour lui faire un coupé
sur le coup et s'est vu le succès
rencontré cette année les neuf pour gist
handisport sont déjà prêts à resservir
l'année prochaine sur le tournoi de la
palme d'or des hippies